- Before we say goodbye,
we'd like to play a quick round of-
- Drewth or Dare.
- Mm-hmm.
(audience cheers)
Okay, alright, so what's it gonna be?
Drewth or Dare, and
please say it together.
- [Both] Dare.
- [Ross] Okay!
Alright, so we'll do anything.
- Yeah we will.
- Alright, what's it gonna be?
- So we love playing games.
And so we wanted to challenge you and Ross
to the Junk in the Trunk Challenge.
- Yeah, so we have tissue boxes
filled with ping pongs
(audience laughs)
right behind you.
- Oh, okay.
Wait, they're-
- You just tie them
around your waist.
- Yeah, just like that.
- Towards the back?
- [Audience Member] Yes, the tissue box
should be in the back.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- And then-
(audience laughing)
To tie it, Drew, in the front.
- I'm working on it.
(all laughing)
I like how bossy you are.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- I like it. Keep it coming, honey.
- Okay, so then you're
gonna shake that booty.
- [Both] Okay.
- And you have 30 seconds.
The one who gets the
most out is the winner.
- Okay.
- Now we're gonna count you down.
- [Ross] Okay great.
- Ready?
- Three, two-
- [Both] One.
(upbeat music)
- Shake it up!
(audience cheering)
Go Ross!
(all cheering)
Come on now, shake it off!
(all cheering, applauding)
(upbeat music)
Go Ross!
Come on, Ross!
Woo, shake it off!
Who won?
(audience cheering)
- Alright.
- I am telling you.
I don't think I got any out.
- You did! These are all yours.
- Yeah but-
- How many are in there still?
Can I take a look?
- It was hard.
- Let me see.
Oh, she's got, oh, well hi.
She's got two, four, six, seven in there.
How many do I have left?
- Oh my god, I'm so, none!
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Good job, both of you.
- Well, what's it gonna be?
Drewth or Dare?
- It is a dare.
- Okay.
- Okay, you ready?
- You know I'm willing
to do anything.
- Anything at all?
- Yes!
- Alright.
So, I do a little bit of working out.
I don't do a lot.
- Okay.
- Don't have the best upper body strength,
so I thought maybe we can
share this experience together.
- I love it.
- Let's do pushups.
- Okay!
- What do you think?
- Let's try it!
- Now, do you want to do lady pushups,
or do you want to do the actual pushups?
- I'll probably go for lady pushups.
- Alright.
Do you want to do it together, or-
- Yeah, let's do it together!
- Okay, cool.
- Okay.
- You ready?
(suspenseful music)
Just keep going.
(audience applause)
- Ready.
- [Audience] One, two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
- Are you feeling it?
- Yes.
- [Audience] Eight.
Nine.
10.
- Do you want to keep going,
or you had enough?
(suspenseful music resumes)
(Beth laughing)
- [Audience] 11,
(audience applause)
(both sighing)
- That was enough?
(all clapping)
- Thank you, Beth.
(audience applause)
- Okay, is it gonna be a Drewth or a Dare?
- It's going to be a dare.
- Okay!
(audience applause)
We've never said no
before, so bring it on.
- Okay, you ready?
- Yeah.
- I love sour foods.
I dare you to eat a quarter of a lemon,
while keeping a total Poker face.
- I love this dare!
Do you have a lemon?
- Someone does!
(audience laughing)
- [Both] Oh!
- We just found some on the desk.
- Okay, three, two, go.
(audience laughing)
- Oh god, I failed!
(audience applause)
I now want to see more people do this,
and see who can and can't,
'cause it was impossible
not to make the pickle face.
- It's a new TikTok challenge.
Try it at home, try it at home.
- Hey!
- Let's start one.
- Let's do it.
- Let's do it right now!
- Yeah!
(audience applause)
#LemonFace.
- We challenge you to a TikTok challenge.
Can you eat a lemon
and keep a straight face?
I'll tell you, I couldn't do it.
(uplifting music)